this program is brought to you by Emory
University first time I met with the
theater studies faculty was during my
freshman year for a theater interest
meeting and at the end I went up to them
and I said I would like to do
playwriting is there a way that I can do
that are there classes I don't think
it's a major is there some way that you
can help me do what I want to do and as
it turned out the theater studies
department had been thinking about
creating a playwriting major for the
last couple of years the major itself is
cross-listed between theater studies
creative writing and English and you
take classes in all three departments so
you get to know a wide variety of
faculty members and the way that play
writing workshops usually work in
playwriting classes is that you are with
a class and you're with one professor
and everyone's giving you feedback on
your work they've read it and they're
telling you they're honest opinions so
you get a lot of direct faculty
attention I also got to work very
closely with the director of the
playwriting center since I was pretty
much the only major until my senior year
when a few other people declared i
worked in 2009 to help her produce brave
new works that year and she was my
faculty mentor she's my advisor she
supported me um when I did a couple of
research grant projects she helped me
through the first one and then supported
me through the second independent
research project the theater Emery is
the resident theatre at Emory they use
professional actors and student actors
and usually they do full-length plays
they mount full productions using
professional and student actors and then
every two years they have brave new
works which they bring in artists from
all over the country to do three weeks
of playwriting workshops and they
develop new pieces for the stage and
they use student and professional actors
to give them readings and it's really
about helping the playwright develop
their
work so where as student actors get the
chance to perform with professionals now
playwrights will student playwrights
will have the opportunity to have their
work performed by professionals which is
pretty astounding
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University